es gibt neue erkenntnisse zu der in der
kür am ide entdeckten verborgenen kammer
wir hatten ja anfang november 2017
darüber berichtet jetzt haben experten
ideen entwickelt was sich in dem bisher
geheim hohlraum verbergen könnte was es
ist und wann wir es wie zu sehen bekommt
jetzt den krieg zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
ich habe zuerst mal vielen dank an alle
die meine aussprache kritisiert haben
ab jetzt mache ich es richtig chaos
pyramide es ist eine absolute sensation
in der krebstherapie wurde ein neuer
riesiger geheimer hohlraum entdeckt und
das mit teilchenphysik zitat das ist
definitiv die entdeckung des
jahrhunderts es gab viele hypothesen
über die pyramide aber niemand konnte
sich vorstellen das ist über der großen
galerie so einen großen raum gibt so der
archäologe und ägyptologe yukinori kavai
im magazin national geographic und das
sensationelle ist auch wie der hohlraum
entdeckt wurde mit teilchenphysik wurde
dieses neue wirklich große geheimnis in
der kür am ide entdeckt und es ist
wirklich riesig eine kammer 30 meter
lang und acht meter hoch und breit
oberhalb der galerie des ganges der zur
königs kammer für die teilchenphysik
machte die entdeckung möglich millionen
haben die kann man nachgewiesen sie
entstehen wenn protonen aus dem weltall
auf unsere atmosphäre treffen dabei
zerfallen atomkerne und es entstehen die
simeon sie sind wie elektro negativ
geladenen zerfallen aber bereits nach
2,2 milliarden von außen betrachtet
existieren sie aber viel länger die
relativitätstheorie macht es möglich sie
bewegen sich fast mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit fort deshalb wirkt
die zeit der station auf sie und sie
haben für uns rund zehn mal mehr zeit
bis sie zerfallen in dieser zeit können
sie die erdoberfläche erreichen auf dem
weg durch materie werden sie dann
abgelenkt fliegen sie nicht durch
materie werden sie nicht abgelenkt
stellt man in einer pyramide also
unterhalb eines hohlraums detektoren auf
treffen dort mehr millionen auf als
unter einer dicken stein schicht wie mit
einem röntgengerät können jetzt auf
diese weise hohlräume entdeckt werden
und genau das ist jetzt passiert
oberhalb der galerie muss es nach den
messungen der teilchenphysiker und
physikerin einen hohlraum geben 30 meter
lang und eben acht meter aber was
verbirgt sich in dieser kammer wobei die
ägyptologie lieber erst mal von einem
hohlraum spricht denn was darin
enthalten sein könnte
das ist erstmal reine vermutung nur
eines ist bisher gewiss zitat aktuell
wissen wir nicht ob der horizontal oder
geneigt ist ob er aus einer
konstruktion oder aus mehreren
aufeinanderfolgenden konstruktionen
bestehen wir wissen dass der hohlraum
dort existiert das er beeindruckend ist
und dass er von keiner theorie
vorhergesagt wurde
das sagt der koautor der millionen
studie mehdi karrubi
doch es gibt hinweise darauf warum es
diesen hohlraum geben könnte kate spence
archäologen der university cambridge
vermutet dass der hohlraum zum bau der
pyramide genutzt wurde
eine innen rampe auf ihr hätte man die
besonders großen steinblöcke für das
dach der kammern transportiert die lage
des hohlraums würde für diese these
spricht die ägyptologin salima ikram von
amerikanischen universität in kairo ist
auch der ansicht dass der hohlraum
während des baus genutzt wurde
da er aber über der galerie liege meint
sie dass er eher beim bau der galerie
genutzt wurde trotzdem bleibt sie sehr
vorsichtig zitat ich glaube es ist nie
zu früh um zu spekulieren aber man kann
ziemlich daneben liegen ja jetzt will
das forschungsteam einen blick in den
hohlraum werfen aber ganz vorsichtig
nicht soll beschädigt werden und keine
löcher sollen gebohrt werden zitat da
gibt es eine menge schweres dickes
gestein und wenn man da rein dort weiß
man nicht wie sich das auf das gesamte
bauwerk auswirken würde das sagt ikram
es wird also vielleicht noch etwas
dauern bis wir einen ersten blick in den
hohlraum werfen können und vielleicht
werden wir alle von den geheimnissen
hinter den dicken mauern überrascht ich
bin auf jeden fall gespannt wie ein
flitzebogen wenn es neuester so gibt
dann erfahre es natürlich hier wenn er
kein video dazu und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergesst nicht den genau auf die
glocke nur dann verpasst er kein video
hier geht es weiter mit dafür
draufklicken mysteriöses rätsel um nasca
linien endlich gelüftet und ansonsten
würde ich mal sagen bis dann bleibt kann